[Music]
even after writing 11 books and winning
several prestigious awards my Angelou
couldn't escape the nagging doubt that
she hadn't really earned her
accomplishments Albert Einstein
experienced something similar he
described himself as an involuntary
swindler whose work didn't deserve as
much attention as it had received
accomplishments at the level of
Angelou's our Einsteins are rare but
their feeling of fraudulence is
extremely common why can't so many of us
shake feelings that we haven't earned
our accomplishments or that our ideas
and skills aren't worthy of others
attention psychologist Pauline Rose
clance was the first to study this
unwarranted sense of insecurity in her
work as a therapist she noticed many of
her undergraduate patients shared a
concern though they had high grades they
didn't believe they deserve their spots
at the University some even believe
their acceptance had been an admissions
error while clance knew these fears were
unfounded
she could also remember feeling the
exact same way in graduate school she
and her patients experienced something
that goes by a number of names impostor
phenomenon impostor experience and
impostor syndrome together with
colleague Suzanne Ives
Glantz first studied impostor ism in
female college students and faculty
their work established pervasive
feelings of fraudulence in this group
since that first study the same thing
has been established across gender race
age and a huge range of occupations
though it may be more prevalent and
disproportionately affect the
experiences of underrepresented or
disadvantaged
to call it a syndrome is to downplay how
universal it is it's not a disease or an
abnormality and it isn't necessarily
tied to depression anxiety or
self-esteem where do these fields of
fraudulence come from people who are
highly skilled or accomplished tend to
think others are just as skilled this
can spiral into feelings that they don't
deserve accolades and opportunities over
other people and as Angelou and Einstein
experienced there's often no threshold
of accomplishment that puts these
feelings to rest feelings of imposter
ISM aren't restricted to highly skilled
individuals either everyone is
susceptible to a phenomenon known as
pluralistic ignorance where we each
doubt ourselves privately but believe
we're alone in thinking that way because
no one else voices their doubts since
it's tough to really know how hard our
peers work how difficult they find
certain tasks or how much they doubt
themselves there's no easy way to
dismiss feelings that were less capable
than the people around us intense
feelings of imposter ism can prevent
people from sharing their great ideas or
applying for jobs and programs where
they'd excel at least so far the most
surefire way to combat impostor syndrome
is to talk about it many people
suffering from impostor syndrome are
afraid that if they ask about their
performance their fears will be
confirmed and even when they receive
positive feedback it often fails to ease
feelings of fraudulence but on the other
hand hearing that an advisor or mentor
has experienced feelings of impostor ism
can help relieve those feelings the same
goes for peers even simply finding out
there's a term for these feelings can be
an incredible relief once you're aware
of the phenomenon you can combat your
own impostor syndrome by collecting and
revisiting positive feedback one
scientist who kept blaming herself for
problems in her lab started to document
the causes every time something went
wrong eventually she realized most of
the problems came from equipment
and came to recognize her own competence
we may never be able to banish these
feelings entirely but we can have open
conversations about academic or
professional challenges with increasing
awareness of how common these
experiences are perhaps we can feel
freer to be frank about our feelings and
build confidence in some simple truths
you have talent you are capable and you
belong everyone can use a little extra
kick of confidence sometimes find out
some tips and tricks for boosting yours
with this video
[Music]